قمه بغداد الثانيه التي عقدت على ساحل
البحر الميت جمعت بلدان الاقليميه وجيهات
دوليه وكانت مناسبه للقاء وزير الخارجيه
السعودي ونظيره الايراني بحسب ما اعلن
امير حسين عبد اللهيان على حسابه في تويتر
ونقل في تغريداته استعداد السعوديه
لاستمرار الحوار مع بلاده فبفضل جهود رئيس
الوزراء العراقي السابق مصطفى الكاظمي
صارت بغداد صله الوصل بين البلدين
المتنافسين في الشرق الاوسط لكنها في
الوقت ذاته تشكل سببا اساسيا في الخلاف
بين طهران والرياض
السعوديه ترفض الهيمنه الايرانيه على
القرار العراقي ولا سيما بعض وصول محمد
الشيعه السوداني الى رئاسه الوزراء وهو
الشخصيه المقبوله من طهران فضلا عن تغلغلي
وكلاء ايران في عدد من البلدان العربيه
والعراق في مقدمهها وامامه بين وجهات
النظر بين العديد من الدول العربيه وبين
ايران خرج البيان باهتا وقدم توصيات عامه
اكد المشاركون ان تحقيق التنميه
الاقتصاديه ونجاح مش التعاون الاقليمي
يتطلبان علاقات اقليميه بناء قائمه على
مبادئ حسن الجوار وعدم التدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه واحترام القانون الدولي واعتماد
الحوار سبيلا لحل الخلافات كما جمعت القمه
لرئيس الفرنسيه مع نظيره المصري واكد خلال
اللقاء على التعاون والتنسيق لدعم
الاستقرار والامن في العراق بحسب الرئاسه
المصريه ومن المقرر ان تستضيف القاهره قمه
بغداد الثالثه في العام المقبل